مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه لخبر تحطم
طائره تابعه لملك شركه فاجن شمال موسكو
مصير مجهول اذا لي بعد التحطم الغامض لهذه
الطائره حيث اكدت مصادر رسميه نسمه كان
فعلا ضمن قائمه الركاب لكن دون الاعلان
رسميا عن العثور على جثته او مقتله واشارت
مصادر روسيه الى ان الطائره اختفت بعد 26
دقيقه من تحليقها وانها هبطت من ارتفاع
30,000 قدم الى ثمانيه الاف اقلت مصادر
اخرى ان الطائره لدى سقوطها كانت بجناح
واحد بينما ينتظر ان تدلي مجموعه بيان
لاحقا
هذا وقال مصدرنا سياسي في شركه فاكنر
للجزيره ان المجموعه وقياداتها تعتمد
حاليا على المعلومات الصادره من الجهات
الرسميه بشان تحطم الطائره فوق مقاطعه
واشار المصدر انه من المفترض ان يكون في
الطائره اثناء عودته من افريقيا الى سان
بطرسبرج عبر موسكو واكد انه لم يتم التعرف
على جثه بريكوجين لكن تم العثور على جثه
مع هاتفه وذكر المصدر ان بريكوجين كان
يغير رحلته في بعض الاحيان لكن الاحتمال
الاكبر ان يكون على متن الطائره التي
تحطمت في رده على سؤال حول اسباب الحادث
قال المصدر ان مجموعه على تواصل مع سلطات
التحقيق وليس لديها تخمينات بشان اسباب
الحادث وعن الشخصيات المتوقعه لاداره
المجموعه اشار المصدر انهم الان يعملون
على حل القضايا التنظيميه